The question is what is the stable way
of solving how to live together across
time and that really is the question and
it's part of the question that I'm
trying to answer,
partly because it's a perennial problem,
right?
We,
we faced the problem of how to organize
ourselves in small social units without
undue conflict and then we face the
larger problem of how to organize
ourselves into large social units
without undue conflict and that conflict
can be absolutely devastating and,
and,
and frequently is so.
So then I would also say that the first
way of solving this problem isn't
conscious.
You see not at all.
And you know,
you may know and you may not know that
there are,
there are different forms of memory,
right?
Really technically different forms of
memory.
So for example,
there's short term working memory,
which is the memory that you use to hold
things like telephone numbers in your
active imagination.
It decays very rapidly.
It's only about four to seven bits,
which is why well,
it's white phone numbers or were at
least seven digits long.
You know,
you can kind of manage that as a loop.
That and then there's episodic memory
and that has two elements.
One is semantic and the other is a
episodic.
It's a.
what's the name of that?
Someone's.
Someone said something.
Yes.
Well there's procedural memory and then
there's,
there's another kind of memory that you
use to represent your experiences to
yourself.
So let's say it's image Laden and the
other one is semantic and semantic is
your memory for facts and those are
quite different.
So for example,
procedural memory,
that's how you ride a bike.
That's how you play the piano.
That's how you play jazz music.
If you're in a combo,
it's,
it's the memory,
it's a funny kind of memory because it's
actually built right into you.
You know,
I mean so is so is the kind of memory
that used to represent your own life,
but it's much more malleable in some
sense.
So what that means is that in your
procedures there is information that you
don't know about pattern information
that you don't know about.
Part of that is how to act,
you know,
like when you walk into a social
gathering,
you don't really think through how
you're going to act.
You know,
how to act and if someone asked you
exactly what it is that you're doing and
why you could formulate a story about
it,
but the probability that,
that it's the existence of that story
that enabled you to act that way is zero
because you have to react way faster
than that.
And so you know,
you have social knowledge built into
your nervous system because you've
practiced being a social being for a
very long period of time.
And of course then that social being has
been shaped for forever really.
And it's the right way of thinking about
it.
You know,
we know that animals organize themselves
into hierarchies and we'll say of
dominance because it's more true the
farther back you go in time,
at least since the time of the
crustaceans.
You know,
when we split from our common ancestor
300 million years ago.
And so it's true for social animals and
non social animals.
So even animals that don't live together
in groups have to organize themselves
into a hierarchy in this space.
They inhabit songbirds are a good
example and they have dominance disputes
all the time.
Partly that's you can hear them having
their little dominance disputes in the
spring when they're singing because
basically what they're saying is I'm
pretty damn healthy and now I'm ready to
go and if you're another bird like me,
you better steer clear of this tree.
And,
and the,
the dominant song birds,
you know,
they don't live together.
Crows social,
but most songbirds aren't the dominant
song.
Birds get the best nest and the best
nest is the one that doesn't get rained
on and isn't,
it's not too windy and it's close to
food sources and you know,
and so then they have the healthiest
chicks and they attract the best mates
and like it's really important where
you're positioned in the hierarchy,
even if you're not like a flock or herd
creature.
Now we're more like herd creatures.
So it's even more even,
it's even more irrelevant to us,
but there's just no escaping a
hierarchical arrangement in,
in,
in social being that is social being
and,
and it's evolutionarily ancient beyond
conception.
So 300 million years ago there weren't
trees,
you know,
I mean,
so the dominance hierarchy is older than
trees.
So that's really something to think
about.
And then you know,
when you're thinking about the reality
that shaped us,
say from an evolutionary perspective,
but also from a cultural perspective,
what you have to understand is that the
things that have shaped us most are the
things that have been around the
longest.
And so you could say those are the most
real things and you can't even see some
of them.
Like,
it's not like you can come in here.
Well it's not exactly true.
You can't come in here and see the
multiple dominance hierarchies that are
at work.
You can't in a way because the chairs
are set up to face this way and I'm
facing that way.
That gives you some clues about the
social order here and you take the cues
instantly,
right?
You come down,
you sit in the chairs,
you organize yourselves according to
mutual expectation,
and that's part of your procedural
knowledge about how to behave as a
social creature.
Now that knowledge is really,
really deep and a lot of it's coded in
your behavior now and another people's
behavior as well and that's you know,
that's,
that's the expectations you have of
other people,
end of yourself and a lot of those are
implicit,
right?
So when we're interacting,
there's,
there's a,
there's a very large number of things
that you just don't get to and you know
that too and you won't do them.
And that way we can act as if we
understand each other even though we
don't because you're really complicated
and I'm really complicated and there's
lots of situations where we might really
be in conflict,
but because we share a map of the
culture,
the cultural expectations,
it makes part of our.
It's built right into our perception.
You will act out that set of
expectations and so will I,
and if neither of us can do that,
even if one of us can't,
we're going to stay.
We're either going to immediately
devolve into conflict or we're going to
avoid each other like the plague,
and that's exactly the right thing to
do,
and so one of the really useful things
to understand,
and this took me a long time to
formulate properly,
you know,
you hear the terror management theorists
for example,
and they have this idea that you're,
you're meaning representation.
The story you tell about the world
regulates your death anxiety.
It's something like that,
but that's not right.
I mean it's close to right and it's a
smart idea.
It came from Ernest Becker,
by the way,
who wrote a book called the denial of
death,
which is actually quite a good book even
though it's wrong,
you know,
sometimes a book can be very useful.
It can be usefully wrong in that,
and Becker's book is usefully wrong
because he thought that it's the
internal representation of your belief
system that regulates your anxiety and
that anxiety is fundamentally in the
final analysis anxiety about death.
It's like,
well,
okay,
fine.
It's a reasonable proposition,
but that isn't how it works.
You see,
it isn't my beliefs right now that are
regulating my emotions.
It's the fact that I'm acting out those
beliefs which include implicit
perceptions.
I'm acting them out and so are you,
and so what you're doing and what I
expect more,
more accurately,
what you're doing and what I want you to
do and the way I want you to react to me
that's working,
so it's the match between my belief
system and the way everyone else is
acting that's regulating my emotions.
It's not the belief system.
It's mediated by the social culture and
you see if you understand this,
then you understand more particularly
white people are willing to fight to the
bitter end to protect their culture.
It's not a psychological structure that
they're protecting.
It's a psychological structure and a
sociological structures simultaneously,
so the social contract is you have a set
of expectations and I have a set of
expectations.
There actually desires.
They're not merely expectations because
as living creatures,
we're desirous,
we don't just expect and so you desire
and outcome and I desire outcome and we
agree to act in accordance with that.
That's the social contract,
and so people don't like to having that
disrupted.
Well,
it isn't because it's psychologically
destabilizes them.
Although it does.
It's because it actually destabilizes
stuff,
right?
If all of a sudden we can't occupy the
same specified domain of territory,
it isn't only that we're thrown into
psychological disarray,
although we will be.
It's that will start fighting with each
other like,
and that can kill you.
It's no joke.
It kills people a lot.
Like it happens.
It can happen very easily,
that are cohesive.
Social Group can fragment along some
fracture line of identity,
let's say,
and all hell breaks loose.
You know,
that's what happened with the Tutsis and
the Hutu and in,
uh,
in Rwanda,
you know,
and those things can get out of control
just so fast.
It's just unbelievable.
And so,
and that wasn't death anxiety,
that was death.
That's a whole different thing.
And that's the other thing that terror
management people don't exactly get.
It's like it isn't just that your
culture and your cultural beliefs
protect you from anxiety and say anxiety
about death.
Even it's that they actually protect you
from death as well as protecting you
from death,
anxiety.
I mean,
look,
it's warm in here.
It's cold outside.
The fact that the culture is intact
means that you're not outside freezing.
That's a hell of a lot more fundamental
in some sense than mere anxiety.
Although I'm not trying to underplay the
role of anxiety,
that's a major issue,
but there's something that's a lot more
fundamental at stake than mere
psychology,
so it's the match between your map of
the world and other people's actions
that regulates your emotion and it
regulates it completely.